if the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying
when i get my new car i get my new house
i get my new relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now well
then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen for them to
feel the emotion
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's
there's no effect of drawing the
experience
to you with that way so the person has
to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from a creative process
and you feel grateful you feel a love
for life you feel a joy for existence
you feel a passion to
for the moment uh you will
not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened it's the moment that we start
feeling those self-limiting emotions
that we feel separation
and then we start looking for it again
well then if you're waiting you're not
creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being
so then if you wake up in the morning
and you come come back to your senses
with a clean slate and you say i don't
feel anything you say
well let me start thinking about all the
problems in my life well all those
problems are connected to different
people or different objects of things at
different times and places
the moment you remember your problems a
memory is a record of the past you're
thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated
so now your body's in the past so then
most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past
and if they're in the familiar past then
they are going to crave the predictable
future and they're going to fall back
into routine
so then we want people then to get very
clear on that vision of their future
however they do it and
begin to combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion
and the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically
it's exactly the same as remembering
your past in fact
if you're not being defined by a vision
in the future it means
you're making your past more real than
your future
you're falling in love with your past
you're more in love with your past than
you are with your future
that you're believing in your past more
than you're believing in your future
when you get to that
moment where you have that feeling
that's your compass because that feeling
is going to drive your behaviors
it's going to drive more of those
thoughts and when you feel that feeling
and it's visceral
no person no thing no experience will
stand in the way between you and that
vision and
and you will be initiated in by the
universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health
you'll be initiated into freedom those
people all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble and so happy
and they feel so great that they would
never
trade this feeling because of what you
thought of them
they they've left that program behind a
long time ago
they actually don't care how you think
of them they actually are so happy with
themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and
i think that more and more people are
beginning to figure that out i think
uh you know if we everything starts with
a thought i mean everything that you do
in your life you
you have to have a thought before you
initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like
any great leader in history understands
that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so
give you an example most people wake up
in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems
and those problems are connected to
certain people and things at certain
times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits
those memories are actually causing them
to think
in the past every single one of those
memories has an emotion associated with
them and emotions are the end product of
past experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the
they recall some problem in their life
they start feeling unhappy they start
feeling discouraged they start feeling
anxious
now thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how you think and how you
feel creates your state of being so we
could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past
well if you live in the familiar past
then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future
so what happens for most people is they
get stuck in their biology so think
about this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion
and an emotion that you can create by
thought alone so if you're living by the
same emotion every single day and those
emotions are influencing your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking
you're thinking in the past your lens of
the future
is going to be colored by the past so
you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
yes enough to see well the challenge is
that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those
thoughts begin to fire certain circuits
in your brain
the nerve cells that fire together wire
together so all of a sudden you start
getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time
those thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so
some people would rather cling to the
familiar than take a chance and
possibilities so
for most people then they say well i
don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so
the first step to change is starting to
think about what you've been thinking
about
and change it and and then when you
begin to observe those thoughts you're
no longer the program you're the
consciousness observing
just simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though
so most people though when they when you
do that when you decide to really take a
look it's like lighting a match in a
dark place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv
it's easier to play with your cell phone
to distract yourself
from those feelings well when you
understand that change really requires
becoming uncomfortable to a certain
degree and that's normal that you're
leaving the known and you're stepping
into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain
because your attention on those thoughts
begins to
reorganize circuitry re-mold the brain
if you're not
being defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future
as you see the same people and you go to
the same places and you do the exact
same thing at the exact same time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is
affecting or creating your personality
your environment is really controlling
how you think and feel unconsciously
because every person everything every
place every experience has a
neurological network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so
some people will use their boss to
reaffirm their addiction to judgment
they'll use their enemy to reaffirm
their addiction to hatred they'll use
their friends to reaffirm their
addiction to suffering so now
they need the outer world to feel
something
so to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world in the environment
is that seductive so then why is
meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain
if you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in
less sensory information coming to your
brain so you're disconnecting from your
environment and we have a huge frontal
lobe and it's 40
of our entire brain and most people
when they have a thought they just think
that that's the truth and i think one of
my greatest
realizations in my own journey was just
because you have a thought
doesn't necessarily mean it's true so if
you think 60 to 70
000 thoughts in one day and we do and 90
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
as the day before and you believe that
your thoughts have something to do with
your destiny
your life's not going to change very
much because the same thought leads to
the same choice the same choice leads to
the same behavior
the same behavior creates the same
experience and the same experience
produces the same emotion
and so then the act of becoming
conscious
of this process to to begin to become
more
aware of how you think how you act and
how you feel
it's called metacognition and so then
why is that important because
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious states of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought is not going to slip by your
awareness
unchecked because you're it means to
know thyself and the word meditation
means to become
familiar with so as you become familiar
with the thoughts the behaviors and the
emotions of the old self
you're retiring that old self as you
fire and wire new thoughts and condition
the body into a new emotional state
if you do that enough times it'll begin
to become familiar to you so
it's so important just like a garden
if you're planting a garden you've got
to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out
the rocks that sift to the top that are
like our emotional blocks they have to
be removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down
we have to we have to make room to plant
a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves
and others when we're uncomfortable
because the moment you move into that
uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because
a person doesn't want to be in the
present moment and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life they're less likely to emotionally
react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and
that is what starts the process of
change and so we have to unlearn
before we relearn we have to break the
habit of the old self before we reinvent
the new self we have to
prune synaptic connections and sprout
new connections we have to
unfire and unwire and re-fire and rewire
we have to unmemorize emotions that are
stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram
that's the act and it's a two-step
process first of all every time we have
a thought we make a chemical
and and if you have an unlimited thought
you will feel unlimited and if you have
a self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and
your brain instantaneously fires
circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or
chemical messengers that signal hormonal
centers and
when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
uh those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that the emotions that are
created from the thoughts are the
signaling mechanisms of the body
thoughts of the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being so it turns
out
that the thoughts based in the stress
hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning and the
brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people
certain objects uh certain things at
certain times and places
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
the moment you think about your problems
you're thinking in the past right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion a
stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past
now the body is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and
if you keep signaling the same genes you
start down regulating the gene to make
cheaper proteins and the body begins to
break down now
that's an unconscious process so what
goes along with that is the moment the
person feels that emotion of unhappiness
or
whatever it is uh the brain checks in
with the body and says yeah you're
feeling pretty miserable you're
suffering
and we tend to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have and so
then we get caught in this loop of
thinking and feeling so
if we can't think greater than how we
feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking then we're thinking in the past
right and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this
and now they get in their routine and a
habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day
is on autopilot and their body's now
dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the
familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists
is the sweet spot of the generous
present moment that
is when the body and mind are free from
those conditions
so along with those emotions that
influence the same
thoughts people start becoming more
judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed
and now the body is literally being
depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources
for some threat whether it's real or
imagined and so then
when you're releasing all of these
chemicals we are literally
drawing the body's life force and
turning it into chemistry
and so for the short term that's cool
but
the arousal that's created from those
stress hormones
is a rush of energy and so then people
use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their
conditioning or their addiction to that
emotion and in a sense they become
addicted to the life they don't even
like
and this is why change is so hard so
then
when a person makes up their mind to
change and they say okay i'm not going
to say i can't
i'm not going to judge another person
i'm not going to blame i'm not going to
complain i'm not going to make excuses
i'm not going to be a victim i'm not
going to talk trash about anybody i'm
just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the bodies saying you're out of
schedule you normally at
eight in the morning you're getting
traffic and you're angry then at 11
o'clock you check your emails and you're
really judgmental and frustrated
the body's saying oh well you've been
doing this for the last 20 years
you're just going to stop today so now
the body which has been
conditioned emotionally to be the mind
wants to return back
to its familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge that
come on this is a good time to suffer
it's your ex's fault it's it's your
it's the government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept believe and surrender to that
thought without analyzing it
it slips by and it begins to program the
autonomic nervous system to make those
pharmacy of chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing creates the same
experience
just for that familiar feeling okay i'll
complain
just so i can feel suffering then they'd
rather
be unhappy and step into the unknown to
step into possibility and the hardest
part about that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did
day before and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious and not go
unconscious and it turns out that 95
of the time we're unconscious so if
you're going to stay conscious
then there's an element that also
requires a certain amount of awareness
or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking are
slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't
it's too hard my life will never change
it's someone else's fault
those thoughts have consequences in the
body so then if a person then becomes
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
becomes aware
of how they speak and how they act and
they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program
and that's the first step to change so
there are there when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and you're tweeting
and you're
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay
close your eyes sit in the in the
silence
of any external stimulation remove the
environment
sit your body down like an animal body
is the animal tell it to stay
i'm gonna feed you you can check your
cell phone you can shower you can have
your coffee
but when i say and so then here
comes the challenge right so and and
then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do
you you labor uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that
and you say come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal
and they notice the body is amping up
and revving up
and they settle it back down now they're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious in the beginning at
first because
david is fighting goliath but if you
keep practicing it just like training an
animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body
is trained to a new mind and when that
happens there's a liberation of energy
the body goes from particle to wave from
matter to energy and there
goes that emotion literally liberated
from the body as energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're they're working and lowering
the volume of that emotion
the more they lower the volume of that
emotion the more they're going to take
their attention off that person and
problem and they're going to take their
power back there's going to be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now
they build their own field and now
there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because
they've overcome their old personality
self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message
it's it's overcoming overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and
when that occurs and the person starts
thinking differently
and they start acting differently and
they start feeling differently their new
personality and
yeah they they start seeing those
synchronicities and serendipities now
crossing that river of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire in wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention when i'm going
through change in my life or i
have a specific outcome that i want to
create i love
to get up early in the morning that's my
time i'm a 4 30 in the morning guy
because
that's my time the rest of the day i'm
serving but
i love getting up early and changing and
working and
having some time to myself and i believe
that when i invest in myself
i invest in my future and that time in
my in my morning nobody bothers me
because that's my time
and because of brain waves and brain
chemistry
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind
is more open and so if i get up early
and i'm kind of between
theta and alpha i don't have to work as
hard i'm not thinking i just kind of
relax into the moment
in the evening i always ask myself how
did i do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did i fall from grace what happened
and so then when i look at seeing how i
reacted to someone or something or i
made the
choice that i could have made a better
choice i naturally
and we all do this begin to think well
if the same situation happened again how
would i do it differently
and that's the act of beginning to come
up with a new plan
the act of rehearsing it in your mind
begins to install the circuits in your
brain priming your brain
so that when the next experience happens
you could modify your behavior to do a
better job in life that's called
plasticity
so it doesn't matter for me what
meditation i do any longer
i like to just get up in a new state of
being i have people say to me hey
miss my meditation today like i'm
supposed to go like this or something
and i say to them eyes open our eyes
closed
you know my eyes open our eyes closed
you know when you're passionate about
something you know when people can't get
up in the morning
and they can't get out of bed i'm going
to tell you why because they can predict
the feeling of everything that's going
to happen in their life
and their bodies resign to the familiar
it says oh another mundane day
but remember when you were a kid and you
were going on a field trip
what happened then you were up and
dressed and ready to go before your
parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected and something
unusual should happen in our life
as a result of our efforts and it's just
those beginning moments where it begins
to happen
that we begin to prove to ourselves how
powerful we really are
so take time in the morning in the
evening and the rest of the day
check in with yourself at certain times
to see if you're still in that energy
and if you're not excuse yourself for a
second raise your energy and step back
into your life
if you keep doing that over and over
again you'll become less frustrated less
impatient
less judgmental it'll just become
something of the past and you'll be
someone else
newtonian world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting a
future
but the quantum model of reality is is
about causing an effect
the moment you start feeling abundant
and worthy you are
generating wealth the moment you're
empowered and feel it you're
beginning to step towards your success
the moment you start feeling whole
your healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect
and i think that's the the difference
between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience
they made me think and feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying
my thinking and my feeling is changing
an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality
i want to take a moment and teach you
some basic tools to begin to change your
life
when you invest in yourself you invest
in your future
number one take some time out of your
busy lives to disconnect from your world
shut your cell phone off turn the tv off
power down your computer
sit your body down for a few minutes and
close your eyes
number one number two take some breaths
and center yourself when you center your
attention
into the present moment you have more
energy to create with
when your mind wanders to the
predictable future or the familiar past
that's normal just become aware of it
and keep working on settling yourself
back down into the present moment when
you're in the present moment
you're the most creative number three
ask yourself can i be defined by a
vision of the future
instead of the memories of the past what
do i want in my life
and take the time to answer the question
as you begin to contemplate
and think about the answer to the
question you're changing your brain
when you make your brain fire in new
sequences and new patterns and new
combinations
that's the beginning steps of changing
your mind
next decide on the emotions
you'll feel when you begin to create
that future
and teach your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
and don't get up
until you begin to feel those emotions
next step
step number four rehearse in your mind
who you're going to be when you open
your eyes the things you have to do
the choices you have to make the steps
you have to take
and review them over and over again
number five
you can't go to the future holding on to
the biology of your past
decide what thoughts you can bring to
your future
write them down thoughts like i can't
it's too hard i'll never change
i'll start tomorrow what's wrong with me
it's someone else's fault
decide on what behaviors or actions or
unconscious habits you have to change
how do you talk do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses
do you feel sorry for yourself just
become so conscious
of those behaviors that you'll never go
unconscious again
and lastly you have to decide what
emotions no longer belong in your future
that means if you want to be wealthy you
can take lack
if you want to be healthy you can't take
insecurity
or fear you got to begin to condition
your body to a new mind
if you do this every single day
your personality creates your personal
reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act
and how you feel change any one of those
things
and you change your life and begin to
measure the effects of you it costs
give it a shot now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through
on your goals 35 that's not enough
that's not enough just to get motivated
believe nation we're here
you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through
when you write it down you have a 91
chance of following through
and when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95
chance from 30 something percent to 95
chance of you following through
believe nation we need to make this
happen so question of the day
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action specific
for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you the
law of attraction definitely works most
people just get it wrong most people
only focus on the thinking part and not
the most important part which is the
action
right law of attraction it's the last
five letters that matter a
c t i o a c t i
o n six the last six letters that matter
action
action action thinking about it alone is
not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest
something amazing you want success in
your business you want a happy
relationship
awesome you want to speak on giant
stages whatever the thing is that you
want in your life awesome you have a
vision board amazing just the fact that
you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are
most people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay
exactly stuck where they are right what
you focus on ends up becoming your
reality so
yes you're going to focus on your new
goal your new habit the new thing that
you want into your life amazing you
believe that it's possible amazing
you're putting up a vision board with it
on your wall amazing
you're researching and watching videos
like this
every day amazing that's great that's
the first starting point but
nothing happens until you take action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but
you're still just going to be this super
smart super ambitious person sitting at
home not achieving your goals
you have to do something i look at my
youtube channel as an example
uh my main channel i want to get to 10
million subscribers that's my next goal
right we hit one we hit two
i gotta hit 10. at the rate that we're
growing it's not fast enough like it's
gonna take me
way too many years to make it happen so
i need to apply more pressure against it
so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal
i want to get 10 million subscribers on
my youtube channel right i want to be
you know one of the first uh thought
leaders experts business person
to have 10 million subscribers on a
youtube channel it's my next goal
great writing that down every day
doesn't make sure that it's going to
happen
what am i doing right writing it down
can lead to thoughts
that then lead to action but what am i
actually doing well i'll tell you what
i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team this week i want to go
back and update
all of the thumbnails in all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6
000 videos imagine doing split tests
on all of those videos i asked for 10 a
day
and so two key people on my team are
working together to come up with what
the title is going to be
and then the other one is doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos
10 videos a day you know in a year if we
did it for 10 videos every day
we're just over half of those videos
assuming that they all work out which
they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day
100 split desks a day i don't know but
it's happening to action
right so it starts with the idea if you
have the idea
but you're not taking action you won't
get results if you just have
the action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're
going in circles without any clear
direction most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people
some people do too much and don't think
enough some people need more planning
but in general most people are over
planners and so
watching this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try
watching my content watching dan lok's
content
alone is not enough it's the essential
first piece of the ingredient
it's it's essential surrounding yourself
with people who build you up who make
you believe who give you ideas you can
act on that
allow you to feel like your goals are
are possible that your dreams are within
reach
is super important i do it every day
it's why i create all these channels i
think you should too you'll notice a
difference
in how you think every single day if you
are
creating content and consuming content
that
builds you up but then you still have to
go take the second step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a three
point landing question because
i want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to
after every book that you read but
that's not enough
you have to do something about it i'd
rather you watch fewer videos read fewer
books listen to fewer podcasts consume
less if you're taking action on the
ideas that come to you
because most people are just
professional
consumers and it's great that you're
consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming
stupid content right you hate your lives
you go watch netflix all day when you
get home for five hours and then go to
sleep
right you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step
you're consuming educational content
amazing but still that alone is not
enough what separates
the people go off and achieve their
dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board
is that last step of taking action so
you're not allowed
anymore your new standards you're
raising your standards for yourself
you are not allowed anymore to watch a
video to read a book to listen to a
podcast to consume anything
without taking some kind of immediate
action towards it immediate action
immediate action it may not be the big
thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's
immediate action
film a video today make an improvement
to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action
teach yourself that as soon as you get
an idea you do something about it
because that's the only thing that
you're missing
the only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent
you know you're capable of more you've
got big goals big ambitions big dreams
for yourself the only thing you're
missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction
pay attention to the last six letters
action
and start doing something about it when
you have a goal in your head it's not
even a goal it's a fantasy
it's a dream when you have a book like
this you can call it your goal book and
you
write out your goals and you go through
i'm just about to take you through
bit by bit stage by stage you go back to
that
but you can look at it you can touch it
you can just make it real
so remember if you do not
write out your goals as a plan and
write out how to accomplish them you
don't have a goal you have a wish
you have a dream you have a daydream if
you want to go get a pen
get a nice little book like this you can
do on your phone too
you can make a document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book
pause this if you need to go and find
one create one
and i want you to pick a goal and do not
even start with i want to lose five
pounds
i want more money these are what i call
wishy washy goals no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them
huge big enormous phenomenal so if you
say well
i want more money that's my rug oh hang
on a minute
hey i've got ten dollars here there you
go you go well that's not my goal but
you
said i want more money and i learned
this when i used to work with women who
were infertile that come and go you know
i just want to be pregnant i want to be
pregnant
so bad if i was just pregnant i go well
as i look at your notes you've been
pregnant six times i know i keep
miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy
robust bouncing baby to deliver a
perfect baby to be a great mum yeah
that's my goal
why don't you say that because you can
be pregnant
lots of times and never have a baby or
you can say my goal
is to have a perfect baby how about this
my goal is to get lots of attention for
what
a nervous twitch explosive gas that will
give you attention but that's not what
you want is it
nobody wants explosive gas so let's
start with a big goal
pause if you need to take some time
open your book and write out a big goal
now you can have
a career goal on whatever i'm going to
have my own company create my own
business
invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow
in loving and respecting each other and
you can have a health goal
but i want you to pick one only one not
three not five not in one goal it can be
career
it can be health it can be love pick one
goal
and then i want you to decide why
you want that goal so much so the first
thing is i have a goal
i want to have my own business that's my
goal and now you're going to go to a
next page and write out
why do you want to have your own
business
so much and the more reasoned you can
write out why the more
likely you will make that goal real so
write down why
write down as many wise as you can and
remember
you can come back any time to this and
think oh
i thought of another y and another y so
leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
y's go to another page and write
out who will benefit from you
achieving that goal of course you will
but who
who will benefit for instance if you
have your own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal
the more reasons you have to
achieve that goal so write out who will
benefit from you
achieving a who how and why will they
benefit you're going to
buy your mama house put your niece and
nephew through
private school did you think of your
mind as like the genie
in the bottle that says your wish is my
command
and i want you to understand that every
thought you think
and every word you say is a blueprint
that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't
say i wish i could be rich
i long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening
i am a millionaire i
am in a loving relationship like well
that doesn't make sense it does make
sense because your mind only works in
the present tense
when you say next year i'll have a
bikini body
doesn't know what next year is and so
you must
write your goals in the present tense i
am i always i have i do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend
working on your goal how often are you
going to come back to this book and look
at it i want you to write out
i am i
always i have i do and i want you to
fill that in
you see the best goal in the world will
not work
if you don't work and many people fail
at this point they write out a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and i think that's it
it's not it if you want to be madly in
love
write all the reasons why but then you
have got to
put yourself in front of the kind of
person you want to share your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you
also need to have the discipline to meet
people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you
so i want you to really understand that
the best goal will not work
if you don't work you can have the start
point
but you have to keep doing many of the
most successes we will ever say well you
know
i had a goal luther vandross had a goal
to be a rock star and people said well
you're an overnight success he went i
don't think so you know i
sang jingles for kfc for 12
years that's a long night 12 years and
people said but luther you're singing on
television that's cool
you get paid a lot of money for kfc he
said yeah but it's not my goal
and he stuck it out and many people have
got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your discipline and decide you
will give more to your goal
give even more work on it look at it
write it out think about it talk about
it you must be prepared
to give so much to your goal in fact you
must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
let's talk about manifesting we are all
always manifesting we're always
attracting to us
what we believe the energy that we put
out the thoughts that we have
so when we're in a story of something
that we do want
we feel good about it we put out an
energy to the world that says
i'm a yes for that and then the universe
responds by bringing it to us
but we're also putting out vibes and
stories and thoughts and beliefs
for things that we don't want and that
energy is attracting towards us
what we don't want there are four major
blocks to your manifesting power
the first one is the manic manifester
this is the person who has all the
self-help books next to their bed
their repeating positive affirmations
they're meditating
they're constantly looking at a vision
board they're telling all their friends
what they desire
but they're doing it with an energy
that's needy and frantic
and that energy is what attracts so
while they think that they're doing all
the right things
their energy and their belief systems
and their vibration are not aligned with
what they desire
and this is a major block to your
manifesting power
the next block is the pushy manifester
the pushy manifestor believes that if
they're not over
working that nothing will happen for
them
the harder i push the more i'll achieve
that is really a big block to our
manifesting power because
when we're in that pushy vibration and
we're trying to force something to
happen
we're not receptive we're not in a place
of allowing
and we are telling the universe what our
list is
but we're not allowing the universe to
give to us
what is of the highest good then there's
the fearful
manifesto fear is an epidemic we are
constantly plagued by fear throughout
our day the second that we turn on the
news
the moment we wake up in the morning the
story goes on repeat the loop of all the
things that are not working
we have 60 000 thoughts a day and the
majority of them are the same
thought repeated over and over and over
again
and all those fear-based thoughts block
us from our attracting power
so when we're stuck in fear we are
majorly blocking what we want
by staying stuck in the story of what we
don't want and the final block
is the judgmental manifesto and this is
the person who's
comparing themselves to others very
jealous
talking negatively about other people in
some ways talking negatively to
themselves about themselves
and that judgment is a form of
separation
when we're judging we're separating
ourselves from others but we're also
separating ourselves from our true
nature our true nature is a sense of
feeling
interconnected and when we are in a
state of judgment
we block that connection
[Music]
how have these different blocks held you
back
from stepping into the person that you
want to be and attracting what you want
into your life
let's start with addressing the manic
manifesto your job right now is to
really just let go and allow
you can keep meditating and you can keep
putting your vision board together and
you can continue to
affirm what you desire but check in with
your energy
see how that energy may be frantic and
manic and
in those moments take a deep breath
release it
you can even use the affirmation i
desire this
now and i give it over to the universe
to present it to me
let it go allow and surrender
to clear the block of the pushy
manifestor it's important to start to
accept that you are
supported far beyond your wildest
imagination
and when you meditate and you relax and
you tune in through
your stillness you can start to feel a
sense of a presence beyond your own
and that presence is the presence of
love within you and around you
now if you identify as a fearful
manifester working through your fears a
lot easier than we think
the simple shift that begins this
healing of our fear is to just witness
it
just look at it just call it by its name
when we look at it witness it and call
it out
we defuse it and the final block is a
judgmental manifesto
start to want for others what you want
for yourself
start to see in others that their
greatness is a reflection of your
own the human brain doesn't know the
difference between something you vividly
imagine
and something that's real have you ever
had a very intense dream that wakes you
up
and your heart's beating out of your
chest or maybe you have trouble
breathing
that's because the mind doesn't know the
difference between again
something vividly imagined and something
that's real researchers
will have a subject look at a dog that
comes into the laboratory
and see what parts of their brain light
up then they'll take the dog
out and give them an assignment saying i
want you to visualize a dog coming into
the laboratory
and just imagine it and they'll see what
parts of their brain lights up and what
do you think happens
the same part of their brain lights up
there was a study done at the university
of chicago where they took three groups
of people
and put them on a basketball court and
they just had them do free throws
and saw how many points they scored and
what they did
at the end is they went to group a b and
c
and gave them different instructions
they said the group a
for the next 30 days i want you to
practice for an hour
a day go on the court and practice those
free throws
they said the group b i don't want you
to go out on the court but i still want
you to practice
every single day but without touching a
ball i just want you to practice in your
mind
see yourself visualize yourself
successfully throwing free throws
and they went to group c and said we
don't want you to practice at all
for the next 30 days don't even think
about basketball don't touch a
basketball
they followed up 30 days later and they
saw surprising results
group a who practice each day for an
hour a day on the court
they improve 24 right because practice
makes
progress practice makes progress group c
which was the group that didn't touch a
basketball and they didn't even think
about basketball
there was no progress no practice no
progress
what was striking though was group b
those
individuals that didn't go on the court
they didn't put on their sneakers and
throw
the ball they just practiced
successfully in their mind
they improved 23
just one percent less than the people
that actually went on the court
to practice i mean this is evidence that
your mind is powerful you'll find that
athletes and we've talked about it in
previous sessions like roger bannister
they would visualize themselves having
success
and so you'll find the great athletes
they don't just do physical training
they mentally train themselves
to see the results in advance so in this
lesson what i want you to do is practice
the art of visualization
i want you to imagine the perfect day
what would a limitless day be like for
you
from the moment you get up to when you
go to bed
because if you could see it here you
could create it out here
because what you vividly imagine you're
rehearsing
one of the challenges is a lot of people
use their visualization to get the
results they
don't want in life and by visualizing it
over and over again
they're actually preparing and
rehearsing for
failure meaning that phrase that a
coward dies a thousand
deaths a hero dies only one because the
coward
in this metaphor is visualizing all the
things that could go wrong
all the things they're fearing and then
their attention goes there
and they're mentally rehearsing failing
on stage or failing on that exam or
failing when they're going to meet
that person on that date and they're
practicing
in their mind so that visualization is
very very potent
everything we as human beings have
created
on this planet was essentially first
created in our minds
all that you see which is human work on
this planet
first found expression in the mind
then it got manifested in the outside
world
[Music]
the wonderful things that we have done
on this planet
and the horrible things that we have
done in this planet both have come from
the human mind
so if we are concerned as to what we
create in this world
it's extremely important that first of
all we learn to create the right things
in our mind
how we keep our minds if we do not
have the power to keep our minds the way
we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and habit
so learning to create our minds the way
we want
is the basis of creating the world the
way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
lore
on a certain day a man took a walk
he went for a long walk accidentally
unawares he walked into paradise
fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
paradise
after this long walk he felt
little tired so he thought oh i'm tired
i wish i could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there
and slept after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh i'm well
rested
but i'm feeling hungry i wish i had
something to eat
[Music]
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they are the
services like that
[Music]
hungry people don't ask questions food
came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full i wish i had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
[Music]
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know charles darwin told you all of
you were monkeys your tail fell away
not me charles darwin told you that you
were all monkeys
and your tail fell away and then you
became human
yes definitely the tale fell away but
the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as merkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey one
thing about a monkey is
it's unnecessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
i say you're monkeying somebody
what does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey
are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind
unnecessary moment you don't have to
learn it from the monkey you can teach
it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a
monkey so this monkey became active
within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
i asked for food food came
i asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came oh the ghosts have come
they're going to surround me and torture
me
he thought immediately the ghost
surrounded him and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me
and he died just now he said
he's a fortunate being the problem is he
was sitting under a kulp of rickshaw
or a wishing tree he asked for food
food came he asked for drink drink came
he asked for ghost
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest
you can barely find a tree
these days
a well-established mind a mind which is
in a state of some mukti
is referred to as a culprit
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in one direction
once you are like this anything that you
wish
happens without even lifting a little
finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want
if you organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain
period of time right now the problem
with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction it is like you want to travel
somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds
and in turn organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now
in one direction if you do this you are
a kalpa russia yourself
anything that you wish will happen but
right now
if you look at your lives everything
that you have wished for till now if it
happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for
if all of that lands up in your house
today could you live with that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important
that our physical action emotional
action
mental action and energy actions are
controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive
right now that is our problem the
technology
which is supposed to make our life
beautiful and easy
has become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis
of our life which is the planet what
should have been a boon
we are making a curse out of it what has
brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life
simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from a compulsive state of
activity
to a conscious state of activity
you might have heard of people for whom
they asked for something and beyond all
expectations it came true to
true for them generally this happens to
people who are in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh i want to build
a house to build a house i need 50 lakhs
but i have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible
you are also saying i don't want it so
on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something
on another level you're saying i don't
want it so in this conflict
it may not happen someone
who has some faith in a god or in a
temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded faith works
only for those people who are
simple-minded
thinking people people who are too much
thinking for them it never works
a child-like person who has a simple
faith
in his god or his temple or whatever he
goes to the temple
and says shiva i want a house i don't
know how
you must make it for me now in his mind
there are no negative thoughts
will it happen will it not happen is it
possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple act of faith
now he believes shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is shiva going to come and build your
house no i want you to understand
god will not lift his little finger for
you what you refer to as god
is the source of creation as a creator
he has done a phenomenal job there's no
question about it
could you think of a better creation
than this is it
in anybody's imagination to think
anything better
than what is there right now so as a
creator
he has done his job wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it
because right now the very crux of your
happiness and your well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is
life is not happening the way you think
it should happen that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is
it should happen you're unhappy if life
happens the way you think it should
happen you are happy
it's as simple as that so if life has to
happen the way you think it should
happen
first of all how you think
with how much focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance
is there in the thought process will
determine whether your thought will
become a reality
or is it just an empty thought or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought
by creating negative thought process
this possible
is something possible or not possible is
destroying humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want
if you want to know the real secret
behind the law of attraction check out
the video right there next to me
i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there
you